tell me what you do this weekend I had a
great weekend I had a really fun weekend
and it's funny you mentioned it I had
dinner with Johnny Depp really Jackie
yeah well I'd like to name drop but we
know each other a bit and johnny has a
band and as you know I play a little
guitar and Johnny invited me to play
guitar with his band and that was very
cool yeah that is really cool I think
it's very neat yeah yeah
there's only one problem Johnny Depp is
in Australia shooting the next Pirates
of the Caribbean movie
[Music]
you calling me a liar Andy I'm not
calling I'm not calling you a liar
but would you be willing to answer some
questions under truth serum oh my god
[Applause]
that's the fakest bottle I've ever seen
it's truth serum I got alright I'll
drink it and then I'll answer your
questions yes now you'll be unable to
lie to me
okay sure ask me anything what did you
really do this weekend I played guitar
with Johnny Conan
I drank white wine watch the Tonys drank
more white wine then drank a different
white wine how many people on this staff
can you name just you and la Bamba what
do you like most about your wife the way
she looks when she's sleeping then I
know it's safe to go in the computer
what's the most recent lie you've told I
just listened to your podcast hmm have
you ever done the show drunk once April
of 1994 through June of 2012 what are
you doing to conserve water waiting
until my neighbor leaves for work then
taking a shower at his place what's the
best audience you ever had the one
tonight am i right people
[Applause]
what are you most ashamed of pandering
to tonight's crowd who's the last person
you voted for Clay Aiken on American
Idol what do you think of the LA Lakers
hands-down the best college basketball
team in the country do you think Harriet
Tubman should replace Andrew Jackson on
the $20 bill yes I do
but it's gonna be a buzzkill at the
strip club whom do you think will win
the Republican presidential nomination a
white guy
why are conservatives so reluctant to
call caitlyn jenner a woman because they
were already burned once by ann coulter
why do you compromise the integrity of
your show by mentioning commercial
products for money because one call the
Geico can save you 50% on your car
insurance all right who's the best actor
in the world me when I pretend to be on
truth serum wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]